the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer rich getting richer and the poor
getting poorer the poor get poorer
people keep talking about the evil of
income inequality this is the living
room in a 16 million dollar penthouse
apartment it's true that some rich
people have gotten absurdly rich but the
other claim that they got rich while the
poor people got poorer it's just a myth
as we've increased the number of
billionaires around the world extreme
poverty has actually shrunk down former
investment banker Carol Roth points out
that anyone who pays attention knows
that as the rich got richer most poor
people got richer to worldwide more than
a billion people rose out of poverty yes
the rich got even richer but why is that
a problem
consider poor me and rich me over the
past 40 years we rich Americans got 200%
richer lucky me I got just 32% richer I
didn't gain as much as he did but I
don't see how I'm hurt I'm 32% richer
and yes that's adjusting for inflation
and it doesn't even count all the cool
new stuff innovation gave me and here's
this meeting claim a lack of economic
mobility the lack of economic mobility
watching the news you'd think people
born poor in America have little chance
to become rich a striking lack of
economic mobility in America it's true
that people with rich parents have a big
advantage but it's not like Americans
are locked in economists at Harvard and
Berkeley crunched the numbers and found
most people born to the richest fifth of
Americans fell out of that bracket
within 20 years like was most born to
the poorest fifth climb to a higher
quintile so make it all the way to the
top one study looking at that top
bracket found three out of four
Americans will hit that top 20% at some
point in their lifetime 3 out of 4
people yes there is the opportunity to
have that mobility and to make an
amazing income in this country you see
that if you just look at the
billionaires on the Forbes richest list
most are self-made
in other words they didn't inherit the
money they created their own fortunes
but politicians and the media say that
inequality itself is a huge problem
frustrations over income inequality
there's an inequality in this country
right now that is threatening to tear us
apart it might tear us apart if people
come to believe that all inequality is
evil but why is that true progressives
like to point out that Scandinavian
countries have much more equal incomes
than America does incomes are more equal
than Afghanistan - incomes tend to be
equal when everyone is poor total
equality isn't possible some people are
just better singers than other
the best performer in the country the
best athletes are just physically
different there's inequality in
everything there's an inequality and
free time there's inequality and parents
I don't have any parents or grandparents
we're all so different in so many ways I
have two kidneys there are people out
there who need one don't have one that
functions should the government be able
to take my kidney because somebody else
needs it how is it not wrong that some
people have so much more than others
what's wrong about that it's absolutely
right their life is unfair unfair is
good unfair is a feature it's not a buck
something to think about next time
someone tells you that it's government's
job to make everyone equal